[Applause]
[Music]
you know whether the extrovert or an
introvert it still comes down to having
quality like you could be all blustery
and all charismatic and all around but
if you have no depth you will lose in
the long game and if you're an introvert
maybe your opportunities for attention
won't happen as quickly but the reality
is is is there's so much opportunity to
to to win if you have quality skills hi
yes good David
d-roc how you doing good man you guys
are filming yeah what season is this now
for it's been great it's been fantastic
yeah dude I got a new dress come on oh
oh just good to see you yeah hug my
route all right thank you I've been hit
it
yiii bottom and I think babban you know
it's just kind of like you have a key
now no worries thank you so much
Bobby babban sounds like the kind of you
just say slowly like Bobby babban it
sounds like a good country kind of like
ba ba ba bababa me from telling if you
want my Bobby Bevan beef jerky actually
you know what we should sort of brand
right now right now Bobby bobbins beef
jerk I'm involved hey guys how are you
good yeah we're just like I'm just
making sure I'm just gonna start coming
a hell of a lot more okay nice bucket
Orsini
very six good to see Instagram started
to interrupt your regular schedule
programs but I'm here with my man James
Orsini CEO of vaynermedia this is not a
ten-pound deck left on the corner of
somebody's desk that is not actionable
this is meaningful actionable plans what
would you say the minimum size business
should be that's gonna be able to
forward every million in revenue three
million in revenue if you are up to
three million already and very quickly
like oh [ __ ] how did this happen I'm
selling on Amazon or Instagram like how
do I make how do I not get caught by
being just stuck on Amazon and Instagram
in three years where I lose my business
or if you've been running a business and
it's been in the same place for last 2 4
6 7 years I like the way you positioned
it we're gonna position it that way
right what are you doing meaningful
growth unlocking meaningful unlocking
and meaningful growth by the way the
model just to give you guys a sense the
model is instead of charging you a
million will you know you know call it
call it what it is call it instead of
charging you seven hundred thousand
dollars a month kind of thing or seventy
thousand dollars a month excuse me it's
kind of like a three month thing charge
a couple hundred thousand but we get to
share a little bit in the upside of the
profit more so we have vested interest
we want to force ourselves to give a
[ __ ] absolutely so anyway James will
give you all the details I just want to
jump on we were literally just reviewing
and I was like holy [ __ ] this is gonna
be [ __ ] amazing I'm going on my it
was like I literally couldn't wait to
Monday I think it's a big deal I have a
feeling a lot of people will be writing
medium and Linkedin posts of like how I
grew my business from 3 to 10 million
yeah in 24 months and they'll be taking
the it'll be a picture of you me
pretending you're now me that's you and
you'll be with Orsini like that's how
it's gonna happen I'm very excited about
it I'm just massively committed for to
blow it out of the water for you and I'm
very confident we can we've obviously
vetted a lot of people to be the right
first choices and we just know you're it
for us and we're gonna deliver for you
thank you know we are the for us it is
it's very exciting and I mean we're
we're talking ready to go to
to learn man seriously like even just
the two days that I spent there on the
four DS the amount of information I got
from your team was [ __ ] insane and I
came back we started implementing all
this [ __ ] immediately and started seeing
all these [ __ ] results and it was
like holy like the 60-second Club when I
sat down with Andi she gave me the
breakdown who's up do you know why we do
that and I'm like well well it's a cool
little I give away he's like no dude let
me explain to you but you need your own
so we came back immediately the next day
I said guys check this out we gotta
[ __ ] do and the interaction that we
got the impressions in the first hour
alone off of just that one piece of
information was [ __ ] mind-blowing
we're like holy [ __ ] that's why he says
to do what I do
so anyway dude I'm just I'm so [ __ ]
excited and like we're ready to like
learn all this stuff and really grow the
business with you and especially like
the way that you haven't organized Gary
like as a partnership and it's based off
of like profits right cuz we're gonna
get we're gonna give a [ __ ] right we're
gonna make sure you get pay back the
money you give us I mean it's a no-lose
situation for you if we do it right it
that's exactly right
it's like a true [ __ ] partnership and
that's why we're like this is incredible
if we really see it's a huge opportunity
the value was like insane so we're
honestly thank you we're very
appreciative to be part of this [ __ ]
thing and we're gonna work our balls off
hard I can't wait well we're already
going hard we're gonna go harder I can't
wait brother
I appreciate you and looking forward to
it do you guys have the contract sign in
the kickoff meeting like where he does
that no we're at right now is I'm
waiting basically I got the email from
Dennis he the congratulations and he's
going to send the paperwork over I told
them we're anxious to get it going we're
ready to sign and instead he's gonna be
waiting on your schedule to get the
kickoff meeting going that we can
moving love it alright I'll get to them
thanks brother talk to City going to the
meetup not the looks she's mean if going
to the case was steeper drop the pop-up
shop in LA London and Toronto soon only
600 pairs people already got him this
morning flipping him on the bay which i
think is rad love the hustle
only 600 pairs my predictions a thousand
dollars a pair for crushing at 5:00 time
New York Times best selling I love
several people there should be a lot of
fun looking forward to meet and greet
[Music]
cue a night should be good should be
really really good
not yet I'm gonna be there like 20
minutes why you Ralph I'm flabbergasted
if somebody wants to do something or
accomplish something that they would
give up after three weeks three months
hack even three years at times now look
there's a very fine line between
deletion that you're good at something
and actually being good at something
[Music]
what up it up puts out and they come on
boxes one day the movie
and I keep the hustle everybody make
more
thank you
[Music]
give me one second yeah yeah where we
feel better now
praise the see in real life
diner own sword maybe dine your own
sword the lack of patience is
justify to use execute on them Big Ups
super fired up to see all of you here in
LA come through here that leg come
through you guys ready every day every
week I would get some sort of traction
that would get me excited maybe I wasn't
getting a lot of views but I would get
an email from somebody that said they
got into wine or I would have a customer
come in and the reference an episode I
think people underestimate small wins
they're so focused on getting to a
million views a million followers they
forget about how special it is to have a
thousand dollars first of all big shout
out think you've heard a lot of second
of all the number one device for young
entrepreneurs is self-awareness and
patience know who the [ __ ] you are and
includes your eyes for 10 years and
execute against it and then pop your
head up
you're [ __ ] young that's your
advantage stop overthinking it just doo
doo doo doo
but do [ __ ] that you're good at or you
love one or two
I mean I'm blown away by people who
poopoo the notion of 10,000 views like
it's nothing that's the extraordinary
your grandparents most likely never had
10,000 people listen to their opinions
on in their lives let alone on a single
video so I think perspective is what
gave me the ability to keep moving one
[ __ ] life do something do something
about it
it's a simple offense going through this
whole [ __ ] line it's just about
believing like the fact that I'm helping
people believe in themselves blows my
[ __ ] face off whether it's me or
somebody else I have my mom and I'm
trying to do for you it's real simple
it's [ __ ] binary you either think you
can [ __ ] do this or you don't and the
fact that I for some reason I'm helping
a bunch of you get there it makes me
real happy but if I'm not don't find
that thing that actually [ __ ] gets
you there because if you're gonna
believing yourself with zero [ __ ]
chance and if you do believe in yourself
you have every [ __ ] chance to live it
the way you want to live it so listen if
I'm not doing for for you get the [ __ ]
out of here don't find a book a parent a
[ __ ] long-lost high school friend and
I don't give a [ __ ]
find the thing that makes you [ __ ]
believe that's the thing that's [ __ ]
working I just understood that I had
something and I felt that I could fight
through it I was enjoying the process I
wasn't doing it to become rich so that
wasn't making me impatient and so just
kind of old school brick by brick brick
by brick and twelve years later he
looked up and
got a building
you
you